because
this audio is terrible
but why
why
okay so this is like
what does that do
okay testing
testing
testing
you might not hear this
why is it so quiet is the question
sorry guys this is not a fun stream
today i'm just trying to figure this out
this is like 4.
level
processing
i have no idea if this mic is condenser
or my dynamic
but
we're gonna try both so this is testing
one the first test and then the other
one
test this setting
what's the topic no topic sorry this is
boring
loud and clear
which one
which one to do this like better
this is the
okay i think
i think it's condenser
all right tell me guys in the stream
which one sounds better this is number
one okay this is option one
and if it sounds bad let me know why
this is option two
option two
let me know in the chat
um
i don't i know this mic is like made for
music is this too loud
um
also if you guys
um oh my gosh i've spent so much money
on this set like i think i've spent more
money on this than i've actually been
made
in like months
we'll see okay the mic volume on one is
fine so this is good
is there an echo can you guys hear an
echo at all
yes no
bottle eight mics oh god no i need about
like a thousand more dollars ish
we're gonna include bike stands
oh god no
um
no we're f4
a slight echo okay let me try something
um
okay
testing
okay let's go back
channels
testing
testing okay it's only like four that's
picking this up
so we're gonna go to the settings
channels four
levels bring these levels down
leave these levels down
bring these levels down
bring these levels down
bring these levels down okay
now
all right tell me
how does this sound
is this good tell me how this sounds
um
i'll listen on my phone
is this good tell me how this sounds
um
listen on my phone
do you guys hear i hear a buzzing
and i don't like it i'm not a fan
i hear a buzzing
so let me let me try to see if i can get
rid of it i think it's because that life
is just really sensitive
um
testing
testing
like
okay
doing a big stream today oh god no i'm
trying to get this to work
i'm gonna have to
okay let's try this
to work
i'm gonna have to
okay let's try this
what is that
it must be the pc
that's always the problem i have with
this mic because it picks up too much
okay let me
voice strength
strongly reach for that tone
audio processing
okay
looks like i have a nice flat i love my
flat i literally love my flat
okay did this help at all i changed some
settings
[Music]
i thought this might happen that night
types of problems
um
um
i need to find an audio guy like torsha
did let me see
[Music]
okay
how to get rid of
background
buzzing
road caster pro let's see what comes up
i'm not edited
okay
i put this at audio level zero
like literally zero
like how is that even possible you guys
can still hear me
try wire
try a wire or earphones
um
well i think the mic is picking up the
pc
what have your mics plugged into the
road caster pro
so
i think the issue
is i can even barely hear this buzzing
in person but this is like a really
strong mic
and this mic picks up like everything's
absolutely irritating
so i think it's picking up this
pc
yeah
oh my god my bags and my eyes are so bad
it's because i don't sleep um
now it sounds harsher
oh my god okay let me
hmm
okay dude i'm assuming this made it
worse
but i tried to change one side
back on
uh
okay but how do i fix it the room is
just reverberating sound off the walls
off the table how do i fix it i don't
want to fix it
i need an audio guy
oh my god
[Music]
asked but i probably will this is just
my first go with this today so
you know
let's see
okay um
this will be a pretty good shot though
right
um
help get a table that's not glass and
get sound damper and pad panels
okay i'm just curious if i mute this mic
i want to see if my other legs do the
same thing
oh because i think this mutes that like
now
if i talk into this mic
do we still hear the buzzing let me
let me
i
see
um
as the other side the glass is causing
the
yeah this mic sounds good yeah and this
is the problem that mic is like 500
right that's a super nice mic
but it's made for music
it's made for music so
i've just had a lot of problems with it
like i might just buy a fourth mic
that's not that one
someone wrote a yahoo article about me
are you talking about the quizzes ones
um
yeah you're probably talking about the
quizzes one
right
that was like two years ago i think that
was a while ago
it's an instrument voice it won't sound
good yeah that i had a whole quizzes
account on
okay let me try a different mic
on
me and tallulah met we have a video that
we recorded i just have been busy i have
not put it together yet let me try
um
[Music]
let me try this
okay
okay testing can you guys hear me
testing
um
bubbles testing
let me see how that's enough does this
sound better than the last one
oh wait
i realized this was muted how does this
sound
[Music]
okay i think this sounds better right
right
okay
clear the buzzing is gone
cool
cool cool let me let me listen
okay cool now my next question
so it looks like i'm just gonna have to
that was such a
refurb turn those out when not using
them
um but but it'd be like a conversation
so all the mics have to be on
um
[Music]
um
okay hold on hold on
okay let's see number four
saying
yeah but for now turn them down because
it's causing echo with no one there
right but i'm trying to get this working
for like when we have people here you
know so i need to figure out maybe if i
turn all the mics down a little bit
testing
testing
testing
testing
testing
okay testing
testing testing
testing okay
testing
testing
testing
okay
all right tell me does this work
does this work testing
how guys prolines donations oh my god i
need donations so bad
please you don't know how much of my own
money i have put into this
you don't understand can you guys hear
me
okay like i've put in oh my god
because there's like little [ __ ] that
you guys don't even understand like
go into like this podcast so for example
these stands were each like 20 30 bucks
each i didn't get donations for those um
the
um what else like i just had to buy like
a camera battery today because
my blog because i'm going to use two
cameras for this oh my gosh
yeah this is going to be a lot so please
if you guys
have anything to donate i would
appreciate it because i've put a lot of
money into this i swear
um
okay
i don't know who megan murphy is
um let's see
i sound much better
i don't know who megan murphy is
well
see and you know the crazy thing is my
most expensive mic
has been the worst
like this is my most expensive mic and
it just caused me the most problems
because i didn't know it was made i
didn't know anything about mics i just
knew it was like
like it was like a 500 mic i got it for
like 250 i think
and
i was like oh that's a great deal right
when it was if i was doing music which i
do do music so it'll be good for that
but like
oh my gosh so now i need to plug this
mic into that
hold on hold on
okay wait i gotta switch these out
so
um
we're gonna unplug this
test before buying it was on facebook
marketplace
and i thought it was my fault like
oh my god i thought i just couldn't
figure out how to work it but
whatever that was a mistake like i made
two years ago can you guys hear me in
this one
because i'm just switching the stands
um
can you hear me in this one
okay
[Music]
okay
testing does this work tell me in the
comments
um
it's 348 over here
so this
one i need to put the original
um
[Music]
this just
[Music]
okay i don't love this mic stand
at all like this is so ugly
let me see if i can like i hate this in
the middle of the screen
it'll work for now you know what i mean
like this is
uh
for now problem
i ordered another one though so
hopefully that comes in like a day or
two
does it sound better okay test one
test two does this sound better with two
tell me okay
and then the next thing i'm going to
figure out is streaming two
different camera angles
so i don't know how to do that
sad i was hoping this mic would work but
um
whatever
um
because i really do not enjoy how this
wait hold up hold up
[Music]
no one in the chat let me know
oh my gosh
this
or this which one
which one works better this this this
this
also because i want my mic to be one of
the best ones so do i sound clearer here
or do i sound clearer here which one
the back one or the one
because i'm gonna take whatever one's
better
because this is gonna be my
spot it's gonna be my good side you know
what i mean
um
so this this one sounds better
second question second question clear on
the front one
also second question this
does it sound better when i have the pop
socket
it's louder on the front one
two is clearer
oh my god that does not make sense
okay which one sounds better
my voice is coming off better
i can also turn the sound down on this
so let me
better with the pop socket
is this better
um
okay let me put on the pop socket
i really do not enjoy this mic stand
like i'm
i'm not a fan but it's gonna work for
now
okay
[Music]
yes i'm not booming now okay
um
i can even put this on did that make it
better
you look like you're struggling of
course you guys don't even know the work
that goes behind this stuff oh my god
[Music]
ellie chill
oh my god chill
oh my gosh this is that's gonna be a
struggle okay wait so what mic should i
use for my voice this one
or this one
okay which one this one
this one
this one
this one
ellie
stop
bro this dog sometimes drives me nuts
um
do when yes you say first mike are you
referring to this one the closer one
yes yes okay
and does the back one sound bad at all
like do i need to increase the volume on
it do i need to
[Music]
anything like that
hold up
updating my instagram story hold on
okay
back one is a bad but it needs a slight
volume increase okay
testing
okay
um
okay tell me if there's echo
how's this for the slight volume
increase
[Music]
okay testing testing testing
that's great that's great okay
now back to what i was saying this mic
better
or this mic better which one do we
prefer
oh my god i'm tired
um
front mic is still better now the second
one sounds better
we're getting mixed reviews which is
good it's a good thing i
think
i i think i want my goal is going to be
to order a third one of this i'm i do
not have the money right now but i want
to actually
um
i want to have these just all the same
so i can make it more uniform like it's
just easier when you have like the same
equipment
um
but
you know that's a later problem
oh god
okay um
read it enthusiastically into the mic
okay wait
hey this is what i can do
um
okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i am
going to be reacting to myself
trying to figure these mics out let me
know in the comments if you guys prefer
this mic or the mic in the back
and tell me how this sounds am i
overpowering the mic or do i sound good
let me know either way
okay next one
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to myself
figuring out these mics okay let me know
in the comments which mic you prefer
this one or the other one
okay this mic that mic is going which
mic is going up and down in volume the
front one or the back one
refer this is front mic this is back mic
i'm
the one in the back you prefer
okay well it's good this is good it's
really good that there's a mix that
means you guys can't really tell the
difference
the mic in the back is more consistent
okay no that's fine um i can switch
these like that's an easy fix
oh my god this is so exciting we're
getting so close
oh we're getting close
[Music]
what's gonna be the dress code oh god
i'm gonna be dressing better than i do
now
it's going to be like a pregame so like
what would you wear to a pre-game you
know like cute dresses clothes um
what are mic preamps i have to google
that
oh god i
that's like 800 pounds
um
when you weren't speaking directly into
the paddle thingy it went down in volume
okay
oh okay
geez
and then i'm gonna get a little bit
better angle i think i need to move this
back
slightly
but that's again you know there's now
problems and that now
another issue i'm gonna have is this
road caster i think i need to put it on
the table
and that's kind of ugly you know
uh
or maybe
actually i think i have an idea
i thought it was cool how you'd show up
in a hoodie not overly glammed up like
over your youtubers oh trust me
i'm not gonna be like super great like i
don't know how to do makeup like girls i
don't have the time to learn it
that's half the reason
i don't have nice clothes is literally
because i spend my money on my equipment
so i just don't have money
to spend on clothes
so and i'm always going like to and from
the gym like even now i'm i have to
leave for practice in like 15 minutes
so i'm like i'm literally always coming
to and from the gym
if i could get alpha male strategies on
that would be great like i would love
that
um
yeah and i'm like getting a master's
degree i got a lot going on
oh my god if i move to germany next year
to play pro
okay the thought of like setting this up
in another apartment makes me want to
cry
oh my god it makes me want to cry that
would i don't even i'm not even gonna
think about that i'm not even gonna go
there
um okay can you hear her override the
drive the mic when she said road caster
trust me half the fade fade her speaking
spell works better with the rear
microphone
it's not that hard to set up you do it
you do it sir
oh my god yeah let me see you do it
um anyway sorry it's a little aggressive
it's just like
everything's easier said than done um my
master's is in psychology a degree i do
not need
um
okay well it's not going to be hard i'll
just switch those in a second i have to
that's why you need boyfriend or guys in
the friend zone
i think i need friends in general i just
don't have time like guys i'm working on
this [ __ ] like 90 percent of the time i
swear to god
[Music]
okay
okay hold up
maybe you need a nap oh my god i do need
a nap
but i'm poor
pray to god this podcast turns out okay
because i spent a lot of money on this
really blow um
her voice ramps up ramps down
i really think that the solution is
gonna be that i need another one of
these mics i think that's like gonna be
my solution to be honest
but you know then that's that's a whole
different set of problems you know what
i mean because then i got to raise the
money for that
yeah
it's this is this is a for now this is a
for now
your my sister always had
okay sir you're gonna get blocked
um okay my sister always had guys
helping her do this even though she was
married
okay well
tell her to send those friends my way
um
hold on one second
okay
um
okay i'm gonna end this live
we're close guys we are getting closer i
am excited i will give you guys a date
soon probably in like a week and a half
because i want to i want to promote it
for a week the event
i need to get people
i need to clean my apartment because i
destroyed my apartment
setting this up i'm gonna be honest
um thank you so much for the super chat
oh my gosh thank you thank you so much i
really appreciate it
um i mentioned oh wait wait hold on i
can turn on phantom power for this let
me let me see if it makes it better
hold on
i just turned on oh wait
um
okay i turned on phantom power
does this make it better
anything you can do to help promote um
yeah just sharing and like liking and
interacting with my stuff is always very
helpful
um does this make the sound better i
just turned on phantom power
i mean let me listen
okay let's see
okay four
okay
i turned down phantom power for all of
them i don't know if that helped
i think i turned up the sound on this
one
um
i also turned phantom power on this
let me listen testing
oh that sounds good i think
i realized that the only reason i do
anything to better myself heightened
towards my value towards females any
thoughts
i think i do anything
um
it can't be about females because once
you get the female then you're gonna
stop doing it
um
i don't know like i always promote doing
something you love like so what i did
was a couple years ago when i was like
no sound
can you not hear me
you're tripping you can't hear me
um
but a couple years ago
i wrote all the things okay i wrote down
every single thing that i would do
even if
even if like no one was there like like
if i was by myself
okay you are going to get blocked
because you are not
could use your own
because
we can hear you and hear you but anyways
so i wrote down a list of every single
thing that i like to do by myself so for
example i like hiking but i don't like
hiking doing i would never go by myself
hiking alone
i like hiking because i like spending
time with people
does that make sense so
i wrote a list of like the [ __ ] that i
would do whether or not i had someone to
go with me so i really like lifting i
really like sports
i
the rear mic sounded better before
phantom power okay let me try turning
this off this is with phantom power i'm
gonna try to turn it off
okay
now this
this is with out
anyways so what i did so i wrote down
like
like politics youtube sports
and
politics youtube sports and what's the
fourth thing i wrote down politics
youtube sports
um
oh my gosh ellie you're so cute
um
politics youtube sports
yeah there's a fourth thing and i cannot
remember off the top of my head for
whatever reason but i wrote down
everything i would do by myself if
nobody was there with me
and i just started devising like careers
i could do with that stuff oh and music
duh music okay
and i realized that i wanted to do what
um
[Music]
stop pretending to be people in the
manosphere oh my gosh
um
[Music]
yeah and so that's what i did i started
taking this is what i realized because i
wanted to stop drinking and how i
stopped drinking at least as often
was i basically wrote down things i'd
rather do than get drunk and that was
like the five things so i started
learning youtube i started learning how
to video edit i started learning
you know instruments
um
i like i started taking guitar lessons
like now i'm almost to the point this
was like two two and a half years ago so
i'm almost to the point i could do gigs
now and get paid
and i realized like i think i would be
the happiest if i had something on
youtube a way to make money um a way in
music to make money and a way in
politics someday to make money that's
gonna be like my third career
so
i don't know that
that was how i figured out what i wanted
to do
but
i don't know it's really got to be like
what do you like doing you can make
money doing anything it may not be a lot
of money but for me
um i would rather do something i love
and make less money yeah so
um
[Music]
aoc oh god no
not a fan aoc
um
okay so this sounds good did you guys
prefer this before or after phantom
power
which one did you prefer
it's a hiss it's her front microphone
when she talks loudly enough it picks up
some of her voice okay hold on let me
turn it down
[Music]
testing
testing testing
testing testing
dynamic mics do not need phantom power i
don't how do i know if they're dynamic
or i don't
or condenser i don't know the difference
um
okay testing
testing
i think i'm really just gonna have to
order a fourth mic that's a later
problem
um
the front one is dynamic it does not
need phantom power but when i turned it
on the phantom power in the front
people liked that oh my gosh this stuff
is confusing
on the box
[Music]
[Music]
okay i gotta go to practice so i have to
go because i'm not even dressed
but i might i might test it like a
little later
okay guys get ready you're here for the
come up i swear
okay let me turn this off
um okay bye guys thank you